first of all first question
is anyone here on a dating app and
has it been a negative or a positive
experience for you
when you see it on a dating app do you
mean like actively using it to find
something or just like you you just
happen to be you just have you have it
downloaded which one is it I mean you're
using it you're active on it
um now I'm not active on the dating apps
but um depending on the outcome you're
looking for
they're definitely beneficial depending
on the outcome you're looking for that's
key
do you think they're a bit more
beneficial for men than they are women
because you sounded like you you've had
like good time one day you know I'm not
gonna lie um the day and nights make
things a lot more simplistic again
depending on what your outcome is like
and I think different dating apps
um will obviously lead to different
outcomes for people so I think two of
the more prominent ones is probably
hinge and Tinder that Tinder people know
today that Tinder is basically the sex
app I'd say hinge probably has a bit
more fruitful prospects for people
looking for a long-term relationship
however
again it's another place to go and have
fun if you're if you're a guy but also
for a girl I believe obviously at the
end of the day it's when I come I'm
sleeping with women to get what I mean
so if if the girls are out there having
fun on those dating apps as well then I
guess it's beneficial for both again
depending on what you're looking for
okay
you're on dating apps oh are you in a
relationship no I'm in a relationship so
you're not on them at all no I've only
ever used dating apps twice
I've been on two dates in total from
those apps that I've used were they good
dates no not particularly and it wasn't
that I wanted to do it it was more like
you know your friends convinced you like
I'll try this out so I'm like okay I'll
try but it was not really for me why not
um I'm more of a Vibes person so I
prefer the old school you meet someone
you get you feel their energy and then
therefore you see if you're gonna be
friends with them or you want to date or
you're attracted to them I feel like
people going for an Argos catalog of
faces yeah that's also based on people's
Aesthetics not necessarily what the
person's liking because that's not my
first
thing that I go for when I'm looking to
date or be with someone therefore it's
not I don't feel like I get much from
looking at people's you said that you
were in like a female relationship so
did you go on the dating app for both
male and female or just female I always
go on for both okay yeah which I think
before you can do that on app share to
be one or the other but
um yeah I've the both dates I went on
with guys one was from Tinder he was a
hatfish
um it was just a bit boring like he was
actually lovely guy sorry I don't what's
that happen oh that's that's like when a
guy takes up like he let's say he's an
eight but he took off his hat now he's a
five now he's got a receiving hairline
yeah it wasn't that deep but I just
thought it was funny because I'd heard
someone use the terminology before and I
was like okay
why did you take this why was he
different when you so hang on let me get
this straight so you were on the app
you're right and what on the picture he
had his hat on uh yeah oh I didn't clock
all his pictures he was wearing a sign
he was wearing the Hat in all the
pictures but obviously I don't frequent
dating sites so I didn't I didn't
realize he was good looking right then
when I met him about it yeah which is
fine it was just yeah and then when you
met him he took his hat off yeah he had
really bad receding hairline
it wasn't that deep but because as I
said it's not all about Aesthetics but
it shows you that people can portray
themselves online as something that
they're not and if you meet people in
person you're more likely to get a Vibe
about the person then I mean even for
like writing a profile the kind of
person I am people might see me and
assume I'm this way or that way but I'm
actually so many other things there's
not enough bio to write how you are as a
person I don't feel so you're more
likely to accept his his receding
hairline if you'd met him in person over
it was just like it's just an attraction
thing so I didn't find him as attractive
so um so for me and then the fact that
his energy wasn't really he was nice but
our energies didn't match it just felt
like it wasn't really it was a bit of a
waste of time so that was the first one
um yeah so okay are you on a date now uh
I have one downloaded but I'm not really
active on it if I'm honest I don't
really it's not ideal I like meeting
people in person like you say because
you get you get like a lot more from
them than just texting
um I think my situation I don't really
go out so I don't really meet anyone you
know that and unless it's like on now I
don't I don't really meet people I don't
go out you know so it's not it's not
really
So when you say you don't go out does
that mean wouldn't dating app to be
ideal for you yeah that's what I'm
saying they are ideal but they're just
long and because it's so quick and
because in my situation I don't really
get much free time so you've got to keep
talking to these people sometimes a
couple of weeks do you see what I mean
before I'm free so the chances of them
still talking to me like when it's so
quick and it's just it's just a bit
longer I'm not the biggest fan of it if
I'm honest
the thing is right I'm of a different
generation okay and when I was growing
up to me dating apps
was basically the Lonely Heart color
yeah 100 like black with these have like
the Lonely Hearts column newspapers so
when I look at dating apps I'm like are
people really that lonely that they've
gotta go to uh I'm curious insecure
sorry I'm curious um has any of you ever
had a relationship develop from a dating
app like a long-term one no no
no so I I'm I've never I've never been
on it you've never been on a dating app
okay I've never been on one time but I
have to add though I also use the dating
apps for recruitment purposes as well
because that's a great place to meet
people who are yeah it's a network as
well so you know him
so I think the difference with when I
first when I used Tinder that was like
my friends convinced me I'd gone for a
breakup just try and go on a date okay
cool didn't like it right and that was
fine hinge I found was more
um something that I'd find more
beneficial for me because you get more
of a profile about the person it asks
you are you a smoker do you like raving
do you go out do you have any pets these
are like it's more like a social profile
right and people can ask questions so
you get more of a flavor for the person
so with a different dating apps like
different different purposes different
purposes and I think it's about being
clear about what you're trying to get
out of the situation previously if like
you said you're old school people used
to date or Court in order to get married
and be in stable long-term relationships
right now people are more is it
something short term you want a day you
want to friends with benefit you want a
sugar daddy you want a husband like
people are not clear about what it is
they're seeking therefore
it's that I think that's why apps are
more prevalent now that's why you're
saying Eddie's saying that obviously
people go on apps and it's for if it's
tinned on maybe it's just a sexual thing
it's not necessarily for long term so
different apps come with different
nuances people are seek an arrangement
because I want a sugar daddy what do you
guys think of this stat
unpopular dating apps Tinder
women swipe right 14 of the time where
men swipe right 46 percent of the time
it doesn't surprise me yeah so surprised
so swiping right means that yeah that's
a yes you've liked and then if the
person swipes right as well then you get
a match well then I I basically think I
think that's that's hypergamy on
steroids isn't it like I've always said
like hypergamy right now is on steroids
and I think women are looking for the
the literal ideal man which is probably
why they swipe right 14 of the time men
uh we're not that picky a lot of the
time like it was like ah she looks okay
it's fine I think it's a cheat code it's
a cheat code for one for the woman to to
get access to the type of man that she
desires whereas for a guy it's just easy
to
to do the numbers game where I can I can
try and get as much as possible as much
volume as possible in the shortest time
that I can
um
so yeah people people getting lost in it
in reality it's like a picking mix now
who do you think it's more beneficial
for an average woman or a top tier man
who gets more benefit out of a dating
app it's definitely a top tier man top
tier but at the same time the benefit
the benefit is is easy access so I think
it's what what dating apps do is it
plays into a man's biological imperative
which is just to like scatter his seed
tastes like you get far more access to
to women if you're a Gaba certain
caliber as we know women only swipe
right a small minority of the time but
if you're able to portray enough of the
characteristics that women are are into
then you have a massive access to a
massive pool of women that's just easy
to slay like look at them to the
tinder's window as a perfect example
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible